you know what we should get though is um
a sauna and that's because i was
cruising my feed
right now and uh before we started and
joe rogan first of all posted this
yeah i love i love his sauna posts okay
they're the best
so this is the caption fresh out the hot
box and feeling like a slightly better
version of who i was when i went in
i think some wild thoughts in there
especially during the last five minutes
when those are over that's when i feel
so thankful and appreciative
not just that i didn't die from heat
stroke but thankful of everything
i want to call friends i haven't spoken
to in years i want to compliment people
and tell them that i love them
the ultimate goal is to always be a
better me but my progress
always seems to resemble a bitcoin chart
two steps up one step down
three steps up i learn but for whatever
reason i seem to learn best and grow
most
when there's room for struggle it's like
damn was that a sauna or did you just
take the mt
yeah that's yeah that's pretty deep i
mean every time i mean
he's taking so much dmt that when he
hits the sauna it's coming at you know
what i mean like it's sweating it out
he's sweating it out but it's it's
activating
basically yeah so if if his wife were to
walk up to him right now and just lick
him
she would just like her pupils would
dilate immediately you know what i'm
saying
yeah he's like babe i just feel so much
like a better man she's like
oh it's friday [ __ ] it
i feel so good daddy no no no no no no
then
his daughter bumps in smells his kneecap
now she's driven the whole family's fun
looking
drugs yeah
the sauna posts are always money i'll go
to the next picture
like what does that mean it's been
blurry as [ __ ] just that's not even the
video it's [ __ ] hot in here
i gotta get a pick of this stamp i love
those and whenever you post pictures of
him doing the splits
oh yeah [ __ ] yeah you know for for a
dude
that you know for for a lot of guys
represent
you know masculinity and let's see
there's one
yeah yeah and all that it
looks like me at the start of this
episode
nice work joe
[Laughter]
we just both dropped down damn joe i do
the rest of the podcast in splits
nice bro killing it man
yeah [ __ ] yeah that's great for man
quads look fire dude
full splits yeah did you guys hear big
chungus had a new song and just [ __ ]
i did yeah i did
yeah we're like leverage on the chair so
we're going even
we're going even deeper than a full
split i did hear
big chunks had a new song legs are like
this
yeah just up by our heads
that's just porn star [ __ ] man exactly
i can wait so what'd you get into this
weekend dude yo this single's gonna look
ridiculous yeah
i did hear big chungus had a new song
oh sorry i said to get that one out if
you're listening on audio you really
gotta tune in to video cause
god damn i am splitted right now
man i'm seeing incredible progress from
these yoga classes seriously
hey you uh getting me a water
thanks
[Laughter]
god damn yeah the fact that they uh
you know they basically
they get their ig baddie fix
from rogan who oh dudes yeah
you know he's out of asana yeah yeah you
know he's working
grabbing that kettlebell yeah all that
[ __ ] around they're like damn look at
his arms
[ __ ] not like that not like that
yeah i'm thinking maybe we got to get
saunas i actually have one i have a
sauna
yeah i don't know how to i don't know
how to use it uh yeah
i'd be afraid having us doesn't work i
don't know i don't know
[Laughter]
just so i'll do the place we're like
this was a sauna
it holds shoes now but uh yeah that's
basically what it was she was like
she was like she's just gonna leave this
on i was like [ __ ] yeah
perfect i'm ready to have some
introspective moments in there
you try to fire it up for like eyes like
you [ __ ]
you [ __ ] her yeah you [ __ ] her she's
gonna leave the sauna
so she's gonna leave a giant piece of
trash here it was i had to like get it
inside cleaned out too because it was
entirely spider webs and just like
sweet gross bugs and stuff very haunted
in there
and now i cleaned it out and then i
plugged in it didn't work didn't do
anything so now i just got this
big big wooden box i don't know maybe
that'll be my like
i don't know creative shed you just sit
in there and
create create what are you going to
create in there i don't know the splits
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
what are you doing there i feel like
asana
is a weird it's like one of those things
that you have
and then you're afraid you're gonna die
in you know what i mean no
i i just i just feel like it's one of
those things that you acquire
and you're like that's cool at least for
me i would just think about
okay so i'm going solo into a box and
turning it up to temperatures that are
like
really hot i just feel like i would do
that
get a heat stroke and just pass out to
my own sauna and then just
die and no one would come save me until
three days later with my dead
carcasses wait this place has been
weirdly empty oh wait noelle hasn't been
back for three days oh he's in there
it's my dead corpse smelling like
bung hole smelling like lard
all up and down this strip she opens the
door you're like
babe i just want to compliment people i
love you i love you that's why he's
having these epiphanies actually because
he's like on the verge of death yeah
you know when you're like about to die
your brain releases dmt yeah that's what
it is
that's what it is this is like this is
like you know holistic dmt for joe rogan
he goes
in there and just turns it all the way
up until he's almost dead
almost dying is is um that's the rich
way to do [ __ ]
yeah you know yeah skiing this
what other what are the things do rich
people do where they almost die oh like
um
flotation tanks like sensory deprivation
you ever done one of those
yeah yeah yeah no i haven't but i
remember that's what it's like to be
dead
yeah yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
what else they do i mean they ride
helicopters that in and of itself is
yeah that's true flirting with death
activity you know
you know what i actually really [ __ ]
with though steam rooms that's actually
my personal
what's the difference saunas are dry
it's dry heat
rooms they just pump steam so you can't
like see anything
it's just like a you never been in a
steam room no really yeah you gotta do
that dude
okay go in a steam room get really hot
usually they have a hose in there that's
just like freezing cold water
okay and so you like douse yourself with
freezing cold water and then you just
sit in the steam room it's [ __ ]
amazing oh okay
you'll never feel better um where do you
go
to one of these is there like a steam
room amusement park
yeah yeah yeah you know like a magic
mountain forest
i think that's a different convention
so you're just going to put it right
here steamer balloon
steamer
[Laughter]
what's up guys i just want to say to all
my only fan subscribers i will be at
steamerpalooza this weekend
i'm raffling off one chance to one of my
fans to steam right on my chest oh no
that really is the funniest name for a
for a poop a steamer yes steamer
cause it really does steam yeah
that's what i mean by steam room i just
like going to the bathroom
[Laughter]
you ever been in a steam room oh dude
it's great you like
poop take a cold shower and then go in
the steam room take a dump dude
feel better you just you dash yourself
in
ice cold water and then [ __ ] on the
toilet
drenched naked and wet oh that's the
worst feeling
you got to take a [ __ ] at the pool or
whatever when you're wet
and the favorite the toilet paper sticks
your ass everything
you got like a paper mache acted like
just
activity in your ass crack the more you
wipe it's just building a mask
perfectly it's like a door wedge
building up in your butt crack of toilet
paper
you go then it just ends up floating in
the pool
everyone's like who brought a toy boat
like no that's my steamer wedge stop
yeah yeah it's one of those mornings
you